moi à cause de l'épidémie de coronavirus
les députés ont mis fin à la pause
parlementaire prévue pendant les
municipales et rouvert l'assemblée
nationale pour une séance extraordinaire
[Musique]
on apprend dans le pays que tout
s'arrête mais on apprend dans le même
temps parce qu emmanuel macron est très
claire il dit que la vie démocratique et
le contrôle du parlement doit continuer
toute l'action du gouvernement et du
parlement doit être désormais tournés
vers le combat contre l'épidémie et donc
pour nous ça commence deux mois de
travail du non-stop
[Musique]
les plateaux sont réduits au strict
minimum il n'y a plus qu'une
présentatrice et puis il y à une équipe
aux quatre cols regarder cette salle des
quatre colonnes d'habitude et bien elle
grouille de monde avant les questions
gouvernement est bien la voilà raison à
sanitaire oblige il y a eu deux équipes
seulement des quelqu'un tousse jeu les
oreilles qui je dois évidemment il me
reste encore un peu de gel je sais pas
comment je vais faire tout à l'heure il
ya un côté évidemment décalé étonnant
dans cette situation de l'assemblée des
députés lorsqu'au début ils ne sont
qu'une grosse vingtaine dans l'hémicycle
qui plan contenir plus de 500 j'invite
les orateurs à ne pas poser les mains
sur le flexible du micro celui ci sera
nettoyée après chaque usage par un
huissier
je vous indique enfin que l'hémicycle a
été désinfecté sera nettoyée avant et
après chaque séance entre des questions
au gouvernement qui vont avoir lieu
toutes les semaines des projets de lois
qui vont se succéder parle de projet de
loi d'urgence sanitaire avec des
restrictions de liberté on parle de
projet de loi de finances qui engagent
des sommes très importantes les grands
chiffres font évidemment froid dans le
dos comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
président on atteint 183 5 milliards
d'euros de déficit à dire que nous
doublons de déficit de 91 milliards
prévus au budget initial et 115 % de
dette donc le travail de lcp ne s'arrête
pas du tout au contraire
lcp a suivi des députés qui ont remis la
blouse il était médecin pharmacien des
députés qui se démenaient pour trouver
des masques le député médecin philippe
chalumeau gros soit à son cabinet
médical
disponible un à deux jours par semaine
jusque là il passe tout son temps ce
moment pour moi cette phase de
confinement et le fait qu'on se soit
vraiment du cours recentrer sur notre
mission première à savoir le suivi
parlementaire l'explication de ce qui se
passe au parlement
ça a permis à -cp de montrer son utilité
vraiment dans cette période lorsqu'il se
passe quelque chose à l'assemblée lcp et
là elle le fait vivre en direct et elle
explique aux téléspectateurs ce qui se
passe les enjeux et en quoi concrètement
demain ça va changer leur quotidien
[Musique]